>> Right, so let's go back to, to 20 questions that we
talked about a number of lectures ago. And we're going to consider the following
analogy. That in, in some sense, what is a, what is a
learner? What is an inductive learner trying to do? It's trying to find
the best hypothesis in some class H. And the hypotheses all map
input to yes or no. Let's say that what we're trying to do
in twenty questions is, deal with our hypothesis class H, which is maybe
a set of possible people. And so, these are the possible answers to
the 20 questions problem. And, X is the
set of questions that you can actually ask.
So X, they're kind of like training examples. That's
how the learner's getting information about what the
right answer is. But no question, in and
of itself, might actually be sufficiently revealing of
what the hypothesis is. All right does that,
does that analogy make sense to you, Charles?
>> Makes perfect sense to me.
>> All right, good. So, now let's think about two
different cases. One where the teacher is going to try to
select which questions to ask. So the
teacher's going to say to the student, here's
the question you should ask me next. To try to figure out which person
it is, as quickly as possible. And then we'll, next we'll look at what
happens if the learner's the one asking
those questions. So in some sense, it doesn't
seem like it should make a difference, because, you know, in either case, the
learner is going to ask the question and
the teacher is going to answer truthfully. Just in
one case, the learner has to come up with the questions, and in the
other case the teacher has to come up with the questions. So why, why are
these different from each other? What does
the teacher have that the learner doesn't have?
>> Well, the teacher actually knows the answer.
>> Indeed. Alright, so let's let's just do a quick
quiz and say, how many questions are necessary for a smart
learner to figure out the right person, assuming that the teacher
is the one who gets to feed the learner good questions?
>> Okay.
>> Go.